Now, out of those many choices, I made a choice to say I'm going to represent
as a tuple of (here, there, t),
where "here" represents everything that's on this side,
"there" represents everything that's on that side,
and "t" is the total elapsed time since the start.
I'm going to represent here and there with frozen sets, because those are hashable.
So this collection here would be the frozen set consisting of ,
and I'm going to just use the string "light" to represent the flashlight.
There would be the empty frozen set.
Now, consider this state here representing the start state.
What are the successors of that state?
Well, any one of the people could go across.
They've got to bring the light with them.
In the successor state, the light will definitely be there, and it will not be here.
It can only be in one place.
At least one of the people will be over there
and possibly two of the people,
so all combinations of sending either one person or two people to the other side,
those will each be distinct successor states.
Let's see--we've got 4 x 3 is 12, but order doesn't matter, so there's 6 of those.
Then 4 more, so it looks like there should be 10 successor states.
What I want you to do is write for me the successor function.
We're calling it bsuccessors, because we already had a and we're on to b.
Or b could stand for "bridge."
Remember that a result of the successor function is the dictionary of state action pairs.
A state is this (here, there, t) tuple.
Here and there have to be frozen sets.
The frozen sets contained people--1, 2, 5, and 10--
and/or this light, indicated by the string "light."
Show me the function that will generate all the successors.
Here I've given you a hint of here's a way to break up the state into those three variables.
Then put your code here.
Oh, one more thing I forgot is what are the actions.
Well, let's say that an action will be represented by the character string arrow going to the right
if we're moving from here to there and an arrow going to the left
if we're moving from there to here.